I think that that human kind has been a
history of boots,
a powerful people stamping on people's
faces.
I think that's history and there's
different size boots and different
brands and colors and inside that's
basically history than the enlightenment
comes along and they.
Enlightenment says,
and you know,
it's it.
It's interesting if you read somebody
like Machiavelli,
uh,
who's,
whose thoughts about Machiavelli,
but it even have to understand that when
they use the word freedom,
they use it differently than we do.
For them a,
a,
a state was free in the sense of it was
not a vassal state,
that prince was not a vassal to some
greater empire.
That's what freedom meant.
It was just taken for granted over
there,
and of course the people existed as
instruments of the leaders end.
And then this great watershed moment in
humanity is the enlightenment,
especially the Scottish enlightenment
where people started realizing,
wait,
we have our own ends.
We exist as ends in ourselves,
and the state is just this compact we
form so we can pursue our own ends.
Now,
of course,
they control freaks among us,
hated that and fought the enlightenment.
Then when they couldn't defeat it,
they subverted it,
and that's the French enlightenment.
That's Russo and they couldn't actually
stop the progress of the enlightenment.
So what they did was they cheapen it and
they said,
well,
yes,
you're right.
This individual freedom is important,
but we have to understand that
individual freedom.
It isn't the silly Scottish English
sense of a man deciding his own ends.
It's really this deeper sense of
subjugating yourself to the right
historical mission.
So you get Russo with his love
orientation around the will of the
general will,
which maybe isn't.
It doesn't mean the majority of will.
It's maybe something that only one
person knows.
And when this robespierre forces you to
submit to him,
he's forcing you to be free.
And Russo is phrased.
And then that goes on through Hegel
Marx,
where the,
uh,
you know,
it's the trying for the proletariat and
it's Lennon words that vanguard of the
proletariat,
the party Hitler,
where it's the,
the,
the folk.
It's the,
the prerogative of the people in your
real freedom is frowned and subordinate
yourself to the work of the people are
bike Mark Phi,
as they said,
over the concentration camp gates and
somewhere along the way,
the intellectuals from the continent,
I think lost the sense of no freedom is
this basic idea of people choosing their
own ends in life.
And it's not,
it's,
uh,
when I listened to people talk in
politics,
I go right back to this route and it's
pretty easy to say for most of them,
they've just taken the wrong fork.
They are in one way or another,
defining liberty and freedom as
subordinating yourself to the ends that
they,
that someone else has chosen for you and
that that's a value less.
That is to me the main contention in the
world of ideas and political thought.
Somebody get that freedom has to be a
self,
a defined process and pursuit.
Or is it,
are they all debating freedom as well?
We take it for granted that we get to
subordinate individuals to our ends and
now we're just going to debate the
answer.
That's,
that's where most people are.
That's where most of the world is,
and I think that's a really pernicious
concept.
In fact,
voltaire read a book by Rousseau where
he was,
when he read the stuff,
he's,
he wrote us a letter where he said,
dear Mr,
so I've had the pleasure of reading your
book against the human race.
Well had it exactly right.
This is this philosophy,
this continental philosophy from
Rousseau,
Kant,
Hegel,
a niche,
uh,
a Marx.
Lenin,
of course,
it's,
it's anti freedom.
It's philosophy against the human race.